[Musica]
ma voi ve li ricordate i giorni più
importanti della vostra vita
molti di questi sono giorni tanto attesi
aspettati come il giorno del matrimonio
il giorno della laurea o il giorno della
nascita di un figlio
e poi ci sono tutta una serie di giorni
che invece sono completamente
inaspettati che arrivano all'improvviso
delle vere e proprie sorprese
bene e di uno di questi miei giorni che
vi voglio raccontare oggi e più
precisamente del giorno in cui ho
realizzato quanto la gentilezza possa
essere potente e quanto possa cambiare
il corso degli eventi
era il 25 luglio del 2000 19 ramo qui a
torino in piazza carignano
neytiri del monumento di un grande
patriota come vincenzo gioberti
cioè se già vamo il 198 esimo
anniversario dell'indipendenza nazionale
del perù
era una festa vera
la stessa genuina di quelle che quando
finisci di ballare ti gira un po la
testa
già perché si ballava pensate in
compagnia dei migliori rappresentanti
delle scuole di marin era che una danza
tipica peruviana che quella sera
festeggiavano anche l'ingresso per la
prima volta della loro disciplina negli
european masters games che sarebbero
iniziate il giorno seguente proprio a
torino
si ballava abbiamo detto perché c'era la
musica una musica mai sentita da quelle
parti nel cuore della torinesità una
musica che risultava quindi al tempo
stesso antica e nuovissima a seconda
dell'orecchio che l'ascoltava
e poi come nelle migliori feste c'era da
mangiare perché un grande cuoco
peruviano venuto per l'occasione apposta
da milano preparava le migliori
interpretazioni che la sua cucina possa
offrire in forma di aperitivo
e tutto questo era corollario di un
altro grande protagonista della serata
il pisco anzi più precisamente il
capitan
a un certo punto mi sento toccare sulla
spalla mi giro e trovo davanti a me il
console del perù a torino césar a far da
palo meno un grande uomo e diplomatico
che ha servito con orgoglio e dedizione
il proprio paese attraversando i cinque
continenti
sedermi in quel momento mi guarda dritto
negli occhi mi stringe forte la mano e
mi dice vado perché così mi chiamano gli
amici
io ti ringrazio a nome della mia
comunità per il servizio che ha reso
loro questa sera un servizio civico e
sociale che ha per noi un valore enorme
sicuramente molto più grande di quello
che tu immagine
gli effettivamente lì per lì non capisco
gli rispondo ma console ma io non ho
fatto nulla abbiamo organizzato una
bella festa nella nella nostra piazza ma
non credo di meritare tutti questi
complimenti davvero
grazie e allora lui inizia a spiegarmi a
raccontarmi che un gran numero di suoi
connazionali
partiti dal perù e attraversato
letteralmente mezzo mondo per arrivare a
cui a torino è oggi impegnata in lavori
piuttosto modesti molti sono coinvolti
nella cura alle persone
altri lo sono nella logistica
altri ancora hanno per topi con le
attività commerciali ma la cosa più
importante che mi spiega in quel momento
è che la maggior parte di quelli che
erano con noi quella sera intorno a noi
a festeggiare in piazza carignano nel
cuore della torino storica non c erano
mai venuti
come se non come se non si usassero come
se non si sentissero all'altezza della
storia dell'importanza che quel luogo a
per la città e per il paese
io ricordo ancora le parole esatte che
mi disse
vedi caro dato su questa sera è aperto
per loro le porte del vostro salotto
buono quello che normalmente riservato
agli ospiti più importanti li hai fatti
sentire a casa e benvoluti e questo
sicuramente un grande passo avanti per
completare l'integrazione nella nostra
città
wow allora in quel momento si che avevo
veramente realizzato cosa mi stava
capitando intorno in quel momento
ma per capire meglio il senso di tutto
questo bisogna fare un salto indietro di
oltre duecento anni un vero e proprio
viaggio di tre tappe tra storia e
leggenda in compagnia di alcuni
personaggi particolarmente interessanti
e inconsapevolmente legati tra loro da
un'energia che attraverserà le
generazioni i continenti
allora iniziamo da torino ma nel 1786
allora era la capitale del regno del
commercio e lo facciamo in compagnia di
antonio benedetto carpano un giovane
distillatore biellese che si trasferisce
in città in cerca di fortuna e che mette
a punto una nuova bevanda che risulterà
essere totalmente rivoluzionario il
vermut
lo fa aggiungendo del vino bianco un po
di alcol ad un suo preparato composto da
oltre 33 erbe spezie ma lo fa
soprattutto per andare incontro ai gusti
femminili dell'epoca che ritenevano un
po troppo forte il vino rosso locale
il nome invece deriva da un altra sua
grande passione quella per la poesia di
yacht e per la lingua tedesca da cui
pare che abbia appreso è mutuato il
termine vermut che significa artemisia
maggiore ovvero assenzio uno degli
ingredienti fondamentali del suo nuovo
preparato
per la seconda rimaniamo a torino ma ci
spostiamo circa un secolo più avanti
verso la fine del xix e troviamo una
città che ha perso ovviamente lo status
di capitale del regno ma che si sta
preparando a diventare la capitale
dell'industria
e un periodo di grande fermento
tecnologico artistico culturale e tutto
questo culmina con la grande esposizione
italiana del 1884 una vera e propria
expò di quei tempi che vede incrociarsi
a torino oltre 3 milioni di visitatori
provenienti da tutto il mondo
e in questo contesto che domenico
peppino un giovane gelatiera napoletano
lascia la sua terra per cercare un
futuro migliore all'ombra della mole lo
fa portando con se un prodotto per
l'epoca innovativo come il suo gelato
ma l'arrivo di peppino a torino in
realtà risulterà essere particolarmente
importante anche qualche anno più tardi
per la creazione di un altro prodotto
unico come era stato il vermut un
prodotto che viene inventata nella
gelateria di piazza carignano e che
nasce dall'incontro tra la tradizione
napoletana del gelato e quella
piemontese del cioccolato
e così che di fatto nascere il nostro
pinguim
l'ultima tappa invece la facciamo in
compagnia di un grande numero di
piemontesi che nello stesso periodo
nella stessa epoca parte per il mondo in
cerca di un futuro migliore così a bordo
di queste grandi navi colme di sogni e
di speranze in viaggi lunghi pericolosi
attraversando gli oceani alcuni arrivano
in sudamerica in perù e qualcuno apre
delle botteghe di vini e liquori
incontrando così un'altra grande
tradizione locale come quella del fisco
il fisco però è un'acqua vita e con una
gradazione alcolica molto forte a oltre
40 gradi con un gusto molto deciso così
i nostri emigranti piemontesi provano ad
addolcirlo con una parte di vermouth
perché per creare una nuova bevanda che
fosse più vicina ai loro gusti
narra la leggenda che questa nuova
bevanda venisse offerta ai soldati
infreddoliti alla fine della ronda di
guardia sul confine con la bolivia sulle
sponde del lago titicaca nella cittadina
di puno ha 3827 metri sul livello del
mare e pare che nel gesso di servirla e
si dicessero come segno di rispetto paro
stemmi capitan
così quasi per caso
dall'incontro tra due tradizioni tanto
lontane tanto diverse tra loro nasce
quello che nel frattempo è diventato uno
dei cocktail peruviani più diffusi al
mondo ovvero capitan
eco si ingegni pendenza curiosità
contaminazione solo sono solo alcuni dei
tratti comuni di queste storie lontane
tra loro nel tempo nello spazio ma
legate da un unico fil rouge che
attraverso i secoli è arrivato sino a
noi fino a piazza carignano e alla
stessa di indipendenza del perù
ma adesso capiamo come è nata la nostra
festa e perché si celebrava proprio in
piazza carignano e lo facciamo tornando
indietro di qualche mese alla primavera
del 2019 quando vengo invitato ad un
evento consolare
al museo nazionale del risorgimento
italiano a palazzo carignano proprio di
fronte alla nostra gelateria e così al
mio arrivo nel grande salone quello che
sarebbe dovuto essere la sede del primo
parlamento d'italia c'è qualcosa di
inaspettato totalmente inatteso che
cattura la mia attenzione
un grande bancone nero da cocktail
montato porte del centro di questo
salone
e su questo bancone un grande logo
dorato con rassicurata mamma chi ha la
dea inca della luna e madre del
firmamento
io di natura sono abbastanza curioso e
poi pratico sempre volentieri il mio
spagnolo qui mi avvicino e scopre un
mondo per me completamente nuovo così
come tutta la cultura millenaria che c'è
dietro
considerate che io sino a quel momento
non sapevo quasi nulla di perù di pisco
né tanto meno di capitan ma in
quell'occasione ho incontrato delle
persone incredibili con cui siamo
entrati subito in sintonia e al punto da
decidere di rivederci presso per
organizzare di fare qualcosa insieme
perché per me era una storia troppo
bella da raccontare
legate ad una bevanda troppo buona ma
soprattutto a promossa da persone
davvero speciali da cui non mi sarei più
voluto separare
così nel giro di breve tempo e
diventiamo il primo locale torinese ad
offrire in carta una lista di cocktail a
base di pisco alcuni con influenze
locale
altre invece più fedeli alla tradizione
dopo questa prima festa
dell'indipendenza segue poco dopo
un'altra serata la notte del capitan
dedicata al cocktail più importante
una serata che vede la presenza
addirittura di uno dei più grandi
cantanti peruviani in attività che viene
da miami apposta per l'occasione
e dopo pochi mesi un'altra serata la
noche della capitana la sera in cui
abbiamo presentato alla stampa un nuovo
cocktail inventato dal console del perù
quasi a chiusura di un cerchio ideale
aperto dai nostri emigrati piemontesi
ap1 oltre un secolo prima quasi a voler
contraccambiare il favore a ringraziare
per quell'invenzione del capitano e in
quell'occasione gli viene consegnata
addirittura un riconoscimento ufficiale
da parte del consolato per l'appoggio e
il sostegno alla promozione della
cultura del fisco a torino
così ogni tanto quando ripenso a questa
storia e mi guardo indietro mi chiedo ma
se quella sera non mi fossi fatto
incuriosire e non avessi provato
qualcosa che per me era completamente
nuovo
oppure se non avessi incontrato una
cultura tanto lontana e tanto ricca e se
non avessi osato poi successivamente
promuovere in un contesto così diverso
beh in questo caso questa storia che gli
ho raccontato così come in realtà
milioni di altre storie da fuori non
sarebbe mai esistita e sarebbe stato un
vero peccato perché io credo che se non
ci vogliamo in ascolto di quanto di
diverso cioè intorno a noi rischiamo di
perdere quanto di bello ci può essere
nel mondo là fuori che il fatto di così
tanti colori suoni profumi ma
soprattutto di incontri con persone
davvero speciali grazie
[Applauso]